venezuela's humanitarian catastrophe has
driven around six million people to exit
the country in the past seven years most
of them in extremely dire conditions but
as the pandemic took a toll in the
region's economy and forced millions
into unemployment and poverty some
venezuelans have started to come back to
a country that now looks very different
from the one they left behind
when alejandro rivas a 34 year old
business owner left seven years ago
venezuela offered no prospects for him
it was one of the most violent and
dangerous places in the world
according to local pollster data
analysis migration dropped 60
in 2021 from the year before
at the same time tens of thousands of
those who left many of them years ago
like rivas are returning
at the border transportation workers
claim there are still a lot of people
leaving but more are coming back the
result net migration is trending towards
zero
this is not to say that the humanitarian
crisis is over this stabilization only
came after years of economic collapse
under nicolas maduro's socialist rule
that reduced the economy to a third of
its size
22 year old danny nunes decided it was
time to return when he realized his
construction job in colombia didn't even
pay for his daughter's diapers back home
his in-laws were offering the
opportunity to help out with the grocery
store they own in downtown caracas that
was surprisingly doing better now he
says he wants to try in venezuela even
start a business of his own
yeah after leaving for colombia in 2017
32 year old javier vivenes got a cozy
job in bogota but quickly experienced a
xenophobia episode in his workplace he
decided to quit and come back to caracas
just before the pandemic together with a
close friend they saw an opportunity in
the food sector and started a small
donut business called cordonas they
quickly went from never cooking a donut
before to having people line up outside
their shop now they own three stores in
three opposite corners of the city
symbols